although there are many castles in
germany there's none quite like else
castle
it has been privately owned by the eltz
family since 11 57
[Music]
the alts castle was originally
constructed in the 11th century however
additions and restorations have been
made over the years
unlike most castles else castle isn't
easy to spot it sits off the main road
high on a rock within a low valley and
is surrounded by a lush forest
many visitors are drawn to the hiking
trails surrounding the castle grounds
[Music]
34 generations of the elves family have
lived among the castle's 120 rooms and
since today no one in the family lives
there full time the ancestral home is
open to the public
every year over 300 000 visitors come to
see the castle and its armory treasury
and original furnishings that are over
eight centuries old
throughout europe's tumultuous history
this enchanting castle was never invaded
or destroyed its rich history has
entered a spot on the 500 deutsche mark
note making it a special site for those
who get to experience it in person
[Music]
you